here this pillow I wonder if it will be
not hidden any you want today a spoon
Red Bull what do you want come in your
pretentious little spoons dude turn the
spoons in there no matter this one yeah
what's that
why did you ask for yours you got that
yeah you're watching [ __ ] money man
you're broke okay it's the dropping
money Oh careful
can we want to do a spawns oh did you
are spawns we're here what did you lose
is this I'm the pumpkin oh yeah I have a
lot Pepsi's hey hey you didn't see a 20
anywhere - yeah
drop the [ __ ] 20 I don't know where
the [ __ ] are you drop it in here I don't
know I don't know where son did you see
it no easy
thank you no what are you looking for 20
I don't know I lost some money not a big
deal I told me to go alright
oh good alright so you guys are still
working on stuff yeah Eric you ready
yeah okay cool nobody saw it right
alright thanks guys
right now alright you need to borrow
money no I'm good I'm good I just didn't
know all right all right thank you what
bar quite apart no it's all good don't
worry thanks buddy you're so generous
Eric hey well thank you though that's
nice you I really appreciate you done
because you're so plum for that come in
yeah that'd be great man
yeah wall burgers I want to have VIP
party thanks man
you're the best era Donnie Wahlberg was
a good buddy to me I like about you on
your wall bar true friend yes yeah deity
yeah so he might have if you drop mine
if you see something you know let me
know thanks guys